[Musique]
pour prolonger à
l'opérateur je suis bien qu'au fond
d'eux aurait tout changé
bonsoir mes petits amis
notre nounours et bien gai ce soir je
veux joueur koch cache un cache cache
excellente idée
je suis sûr que tes amis seront très
contents hop hop hop hop hop hop
un
[Musique]
coucou
il ya personne pour jouer à cache-cache
[Musique]
au jeu les photos
qu'est ce que c'est
ça bouge
sérieux champions nous ils prônent eux
ou et offreurs
nikolas
nikos et
doit alors je veux une bonne que chacun
devienne
saulieu jeunes et où les enfers c'est à
moi de me cacher rien sinon à moi seul
que vous me chercher je vous préviens
que j'ai une cachette très difficile à
trouver et mahler trop gras tu vas voir
comme on invite les trouver
moi je me bats on leur laisse
[Musique]
une visite
dieu l'a
connais shoah salle alors que malade non
merci je veux tu règles météo les joies
casque hot pot histoire je me cache
aussi
alors ça y est coucou nous nous at il
plus cachés derrière les rideaux
non
sourit
gros comme il est on devrait trouver
coco là dessus
et bien que ces lits
ses yeux le 12 août à trouver
bonsoir
cornichons
tout et ça c'est une bonne farce eh bien
je viens vous voir et nano
toof
ouf de l'air ça fait du bien mon pauvre
nous nous
ça elles étaient marta youth mais bien
les enfants je vous laisse la place
votre lit vous attend et cornichons
t'inquiète pas je vais choisir mon coin
et juliette à l est pas venu avec toi
non elle va me rejoindre toute seule
elle connaît le chemin c'est formidable
quand même avis
ce soir on se couche demain nous ferons
encore une grande partie de cache cache
je me sens
bono ni le petit
d'homme
[Musique]
patron quelle surprise cornichons la
revue et bien je connais deux petits
enfants qui sont contents le nounours
aussi uni vent oui en route de nuit les
enfants faute de bord
[Musique]